ilk girişim 12 yaşındayım parlak geçen
Akademik olarak parlak geçen bir ilkokul
Sofrası sonrası Tarsus'a gitsem mi
gitmesem mi karar vermeye çalışıyoruz
maddi olarak mütevazi bir aileden
geliyorum Dolayısıyla buraya da burslu
olarak kazandığım için acaba gitmeli
miyim gitmemeli miyim
gittiğim zaman başarılı olabilir miyim
Çünkü Mersin ve çevresindeki en başarılı
öğrencilerin geldiği tercih ettiği bir
okul acaba gidebilir miyim orada
başarılı olabilir miyim aldığım bursu
devam ettirebilir miyim gibi kaygılar
sonrasında
bu riski göze alarak Tarsus'a başladım 7
sene dolu dolu geçen bir 7 sene kendimi
çok geliştirdiğim bir çok şey öğrendiğim
hem Tarsus camiasından hem mezunlar
camiasından
2003'te
lise sondayız
üniversite sınavlarını Hazırlanıyoruz
bir yandan da hiç daha önce Aslında
bilmediğim pek Aşina olmadım Amerika'da
bir üniversiteye gitme Fikri
genel itibariyle Türkiye'de ÖSS'ye
hazırlanayım sınavlara gireyim iyi bir
okula geleyim iyi bir meslek edineyim
gibi bir kariyer çizmeye çalışıyorum
kendimi ama bir yandan da özellikle
yakın arkadaşlarımın
cesaretlendirmesiyle
Amerika'da iyi okullara başvurayım
Burası bir Amerikan Koleji itibariyle ve
bizim Bizden önceki dönemlerde de hep
iyi okullara giden örnekleri görüyoruz
Dolayısıyla acaba mı diyerek Bir
şansımızı deneme şeklinde
Amerika'daki üniversitelerde başvurdum
Mayıs gibi ÖSS artık bir aylık bir dönem
kalmış Mayıs gibi harvar'da full burst
olarak kabul edildiğim
bilgisini aldım tabi çok sevindim
Türkiye'de de sınava girip ÖSS'de bir
yere kayıt dondurma gibi ama bir Backup
falan da yapıyorum çünkü Amerika'ya da
bilmiyorum Daha önce bir kere bir kamp
için gitmiştim ama onun dışında çok
Aşina olduğumuz bir yer değil ailemin de
Aşina olduğu bir yer değil
Dolayısıyla gidip orada o ortamda o
kontekste Başarılı olabilecek miyim
istediklerimi gerçekleştirebilecek miyim
Bir çok soru
fakat yine bir risk alarak
Konfor alanımızdan biraz çıkarak
eğitimi Amerika'ya gittim
mezun olduktan sonra yine
Global anlamda çok Saygın olan bir
danışmanlık şirketlerinden birinde işe
başladım
seneye 2007
bunun 25 senesi İngiltere'de geçti Geri
kalanını Türkiye'de geçti bu süre
zarfında 15 yıl 15 yıl boyunca oliver'da
danışmanlık yaptım
süre zarfında birkaç yerde hep şeyi
düşündüm acaba
farklı bir şey yapsam mı farklı bir
şirkete mi geçsem veya sektöre mi geçsem
finansal hizmetler sektöründe hizmet
veriyorum İlk başlarda çok güzeldi
sürekli seyahattesiniz yurt dışına
gidiyorsunuz işte brezilya'dan Rusya'ya
Fransa'ya
Yunanistan'a birçok ülkede
birkaç aylık projeler yapacak bir şeye
sahipsiniz imkana sahipsiniz bunun
beslenme içerisinde Çok çalışarak şirket
içerisinde kendime bir Network edinerek
şirket dışında bir portföy yaratarak
satış yapabileceğim olabildiğince
kendimi yukarıya taşımaya çalıştığım bir
15 yıl
yine 2 veya 3 noktada acaba Çıksam mı
başka bir yere gitsem mi burada artık
çoklu zaman geçirdim biraz kendime
farklı bir perspektif atacak bir yere mi
gitsem gibi düşünceler ama her seferinde
kendi kendime yani burada kalmak daha
iyi burada bir oturmuş bir düzenim de
var bu şekilde devam edeyim finansal
anlamda da tatmin edici entelektüel
anlamda da tatmin edici Sonuçta birçok
finansal kuruluşun üst tabakasıyla
yönetimiyle işler yapıyorsunuz onlara
danışmanlık hizmeti veriyorsunuz
15 sene böyle geçti 2018'de
Partner Trakya girdim
Partner olmak için bir komiteye
gidiyorsunuz orada komitede herkesin
Sizin farklı seçilmenizi Okey vermesi
gerekiyor Yoksa geçemiyorsunuz
danışmanlıktaki en zorlu adımdır bir
çabayla o aşamayı da geçip 2018'de
Partner oldum şimdi her şey böyle iyi
gidiyor sene geldi
2021'e 21'in sonu
kapatmaya karar verdim
strateji değişikliğine gitti şirket daha
nispeten küçük olan yerlerdeki ofisleri
kapatıp büyük pazarlara işte Almanya
İngiltere Amerika gibi büyük pazarlara
odaklanmaya karar verdi
Peki zaten Avrupa'da çalışıyorsun çoğu
işin orada istersen seni Avrupa'da
herhangi bir yere transfer edelim
istersen Türkiye'de yaşa sadece hani
resmi olarak transfer ederim yaşamın
yine İstanbul'da kalsın gitmeye gelmeye
devam et istediğin gibi devam
maalesef ülkenin durumundan dolayı da
herkes zaten bir yurt dışına gitme
fırsatı da arıyor
Ama bu benim için de bir işaret oldu Ne
yaptım bu haber sektörde doğrulduktan
sonra başka danışmanlık şirketleri direk
iletişime geçtiler hizmet verdiğin
bankacılık müşterileri üst seviyedeki
yiyorlar ve çeşitli başka pozisyondaki
kişiler
iletişime geçmeye başladı çeşitli
pozisyonlar önerdiler Hatta teklif de
verdiler Tüm bu sürelerden Bu süreçten
geçerken hiç beklenmedik bir şekilde
üniversite zamanlarından tanıdığım bir
arkadaşımın aracılığıyla getir de bir
görüşmeye gittim arkadaşımla bir kahve
içtik dedi ki bana ya bize gelmez misin
Biz de çalışmaz mısın dedim ben
bankacılıkta çalışıyorum finansal
hizmetler benim alanı marketçilikten
anlamam çok kurumsal yapıların
içindeydim ya bankalar olabileceğiniz en
kurumsal iletişim
ülkelerinin oturmuş olduğu Yüzyıllık
yüzyıllarca
etrafta olan organizasyonlar
Hem o dünyadan getir gibi daha birkaç
senedir burada olan bir anda çok büyümüş
bir
Türkiye'den çıkan iyi bir marka ama
içerisi biraz Muhtemelen kaotik bunların
hepsini düşünüyorum
arkadaşım dedi şey yapma merak etme
gelirsin içeriye Hepimiz böyle biraz
benzer bir şekilde geldik ve kendi
yolunu çizersin şimdi
15 sene danışmanlık yapmışım artık
danışmanlığın en son kadimesine de
gelmişim finansal anlamda da çok iyi bir
yerdeyim Bir tane çocuğum da olmuş
İkincisi de gelecek inşallah onu da
düşünüyoruz O zamanlar
böyle bir
durumda ve şeye de geçebilirsiniz yani
benzer bir şirkete de geçebilirsiniz
finansta devam edebilirsiniz yani o
Konfor alanının içerisinde devam
edebileceğim bir
seçim de var Bunların arasında getirilen
bu şekilde bir teklif geliyor burada
kaçınınız böyle bir teklifi kabul
ederdiniz size gelse
hiç el görmüyorum
Demek ki hiçbiriniz Konfor alanınızın
dışarı çıkmaya pek hazır değilsiniz
Benim konumda olsanız Ben Konfor
alanından dışını Konfor alanının dışına
çıkmaya karar verdim Hiç bilmediğim bir
sektörde
üst düzey bir yönetici olarak şirkete
Hatta hiçbir taytının da olmadan İlk
gittiğinde titanım yoktu yani ünvanım
yoktu üst düzey yönetici şeklinde geçtim
Çünkü kurucular bana dedi ki gel içeride
sen biraz şirketi tanı biz seni biraz
tanıyalım bir şekilde bir yere varırız
şimdi bu hem çok güzel bir fırsat hem de
çok riskli bir şey Çünkü yine yeni bir
sektörü öğrenmek zorunda kalacağım
Başarılı olabilecek miyim içeride
Kendime yer edinebilecek miyim
kaygılarım
Ama o adımı atmaya karar verdim O adımı
attıktan sonra yaşadıklarımla geçtiğim
evrelerle ilgili biraz size bunlardan
bahsetmek istiyorum sohbet etmek
istiyorum Öncelikle
4 aşamadan geçtiğimi söyleyebilirim ilk
aşama Konfor alanıydı zaten Konfor
alanımın içerisindeydim dışarısına
çıkmamak için bir sürü sebep var
literatüre baksanız Konfor alanını
insanın kendini kontrolde hissettiği ve
güvende hissettiği bir psikolojik evre
olarak açıklanıyor
o bölgede Burada da çok güzel bir örnek
var aslında Şurayı Konfor alanı diyelim
kırmızı halıyı buranın içerisindeki her
şey size tanıdık daha önce tecrübe
ettiğiniz şeyler bir şeyle
interaktifseniz sonucunun ne olduğunu
biliyorsunuz dolayısıyla çok rahat bir
alan çıkması buradan dışarıya bir adım
atması birçok kişi için çok zor yıllar
geçtikçe bu Konfor alanında sürekli
kaldıkça Konfor alanının çevresindeki bu
çizgide kalınlaşmaya başlıyor yükselmeye
başlıyor çıkması daha da zor olmaya
başlıyor
Çünkü neden buradan dışarıya çıkarsanız
aslında sizi bekleyen şey bilinmezlik
belirgin olmaması Yani gerçekten
çıktığım anda Nereye gideceğim
sonrasında bu yolculuk nereye varacak
net olarak bilmediğimiz bir şey bu
birçok insanı hepimizi
normal olarak çok korkutan bir şey ben
ilk deneyim İlk savaşımı o Konfor
alanından dışarıya çıkmak da verdim
eşimle konuştum Hatta böyle bir kararda
Bir türlü karar veremiyorum Ne yapalım
Ne yapmalıyım Eşim bana şunu dedi Ve o
zaten benim Direkt getirdi teklifi kabul
etmeme sebep oldu dedi ki diğer
yerlerden de teklifler aldım Hepsini
gelip bana anlattın bu anlattığın Yani
bunu anlatırken ki o motivasyon
gözündeki ışığı Ben diğerlerinde
göremedim Çünkü onlar hep aynı şeyin
biraz uzantısı devamı gibi bu yeni bir
şey olduğu için benim de heyecanlandıran
acaba mı dedirten yeni bir şeydi Onun
için Konfor alanından çıkmaya karar
verdim ve o yıkadım Sonrasında ne geldi
ikinci aşama korku ve endişe şimdi
buradan dışarıya adımımızı attığınızda
Artık deneyimlemediğiniz içinde Bu
deneyimlemediniz bir sürü şey oluyor
içinde bulunmadığınız bir sürü ortamda
ve
durumda bulunmak zorunda kalıyorsunuz
sonucunda bilmiyorsunuz Bu alanın
Yerçekimi gibi gerçekten çok büyük bir
çekim gücü var acaba mı diye kendinizi
Kendinizden şüphe etmeye başladığınızda
bu Konfor alanına geri girmek çok kolay
ben yarın
getirilen istifa edip tekrar benzer bir
şirkete veya bankacılık sektörüne çok
rahat bir şekilde geri dönebilirim
Çıktığım zaman ilk zamanlarda da İlk
birkaç ayda
getire gittim taytım unvanım üst düzey
yönetici insanlarla tanışıyorum
departman başkanları ile tanışıyorum ne
yapıyorsunuz ne ediyorsunuz bana anlatın
diyorum şimdi anlatıyorlar Sonrasında da
doğal olarak şey soruyorlar Siz ne
yapacaksınız sizin rolünüz Ne olacak bu
organizasyonda nereye oturacaksınız Buna
cevap veremiyorum bakacağız diyorum
Çünkü bilmiyorum Bir ekibim henüz yok
Tek başımayım ve üst düzey bir yönetici
olarak gün bir itibarıyla bir katkı
sağlamanız bekleniyor şirketi
dolayısıyla bir yaklaşık 2-3 aylık bir
süre bu korku ve endişeyle geçti yani
ben acaba doğru kararı verdim mi bu
yanlış karar mıydı bu organizasyonda
kendime bir yer edinebilecek miyim
ünvan çift afişion unvanı sonradan geldi
ve kurucularla beraber ajanda sürekli o
aralar ben katıldığım zamanlar sürekli
verimlilikten bahsediyorduk
şirketin bir anda çok hızlı büyüdü
birçok ülkeye açıldığını ve o hızlı
büyümenin biraz verimsizlikle
yapıldığını dolayısıyla biraz içeri
bakalım verimliliği artıralım gibi bir
ajanda vardı o ajandadan çıkan Aslında
etrafa baktığınızda birçok şirkette
görmeyeceğinizde o şekilde çıktı ve
benim taytımı aldım Şimdi bu taytı
verimlilik çok yatay bir şeydir Bir sürü
insanın etki alanına girmek zorunda
kalırsınız zaten geldiğimde bir sürü
başka yönetici de var herkesin alanına
girip verimliliği arttırıcı şeyler
yapmaya yapmalarını söylemeniz gerekir
veya onları bir yerine götürmeniz
gerekir Zaten yabancı olduğum bir
ortamda Henüz bir ekibim de yok tek
başıma bu
şeyin naviga etmek bütün bu durumuna
hediye etmek bayağı zor bir Ee
zor bir durumdur Yaklaşık 3 ay boyunca
bunu yaptım bir ajanda çıkardım
verimlilik konusunda şunları yapabiliriz
dedim kuruculara sundum çok iyi
reaksiyonlar aldım Bunların hepsi çok
önemli şeyler gidip hemen yapalım
kendine bir ekip kurur direkt bunları
yapmaya başla diye bir
onlardan da güç aldım sonrasında
bu korku ve endişeyi biraz
atmaya başladı çünkü yavaş yavaş
organizasyon içerisinde kendi yerimi de
edinmeye başladım şirket tanımaya
başladım onlar beni tanımaya başladı O
şekilde üçüncü evreye geçtim yani
öğrenme ve adaptasyon artık bu işin
nasıl yapıldığını da görüyorum
parçaları birbirine nasıl
birleştirilmesi gerektiğini de biliyorum
artık bunları öğrendiğime göre üzerine
bir şeyler de koyabilirim gibi bir
evreye gitmeye başladım ekipler kurdum
Avrupa'da görevlendirmemi istedi
kurucular Avrupa'ya bakmaya başladı
Avrupa'da 7 tane pazardayız Biz şu an ve
ben Güney Avrupa ülkelerinin Ee yönetimi
bende aynı zamanda Avrupa bölgesindeki
çeşitli Ee fonksiyonların liderliği de
bende dolayısıyla bir öğrenme ve
adaptasyon sürecinden geçip
şu an bulunduğum aşamada büyüme aşaması
diye adlandırdığım yani artık bir
şeylerin üzerine
inşa edebiliyorum artık gittiğim yerleri
bir
ekibim var büyük de bir ekibim var
Yaklaşık bütün ülkeleri
düşünürseniz yine Avrupa 3000 kişilik
bir organizasyonu Aslında yöneticilik
yapıyorum
öğrenmediğim Bir sürü şeyi öğreniyorum
daha önceki hayatımda karşılaşmadığım
daha önceki profesyon hayatımla
karşılaşmadım birçok şeyle
karşılaşıyorum Çünkü bir önceki
hayatımda daha çok böyle yönetim kurulu
odaları siyo odalarında geziniyordum
diyeyim onlarla konuşuyordum burada
kurye ile bayiyle
diyaloğa geçmeye başladık çok daha
farklı yerlere gitmeye başladı ve o
öğrenme ve adaptasyon hızlı öğrenme ve
adaptasyon beni kişisel olarak da
geliştiren bir noktaya götürmeye başladı
şu an Geriye baktığımda bir bir yılı
Biraz geçti getirdi bir yıl olmasına
rağmen sanki danışmanlıktaki 15 yılın
böyle 5-6 senesini bir yıla sıkıştırıp
yaşamış gibi bir Ee aleti Rüya
içerisindeyim diyebilirim
şimdi Buradan sonra nereye gidecek iş
diye de kendi kendime de düşünmeye
başladım Çünkü bu benim yaptığım Konfor
alanından çıktığım Ee hayatımdaki en
büyük
aşamaydı bundan sonrasında kendi kendime
şöyle düşünmeye başladım
derken
neyse
bu 4 aşama geçti bu 4 aşamayı birbiri
içerisinde büyük
daireler şeklinde düşünelim Konfor
alanıyla başladık bir daire çizdik korku
alanına girdik bir daire daha çizdik
daha büyük bir daire öğrenme ve
adaptasyon alanına girdik bir daire daha
çizdik büyüme alanına girdik şimdi bir
süre sonra bu büyük circle Artık yeni
Konfor alanınız olmaya başlıyor
artık daha büyük bir Konfor alanınız var
daha geniş daha fazla şeye hakimsiniz o
alanın içerisinde çok daha fazla şey var
ama bu yeni bir Konfor alanı olmaya
başlıyor Dolayısıyla bundan sonrasında
yine kariyer yolculuğuma baktığımda
Muhtemelen bir süre sonra kendimi yine
Konfor alanının dışına atacak bir şeyler
yapmaya içeceğim diye düşünüyorum Eğer
birkaç sene sonra diyelim yine buraya
gelip konuşma fırsatı bulursam belki
bundan sonraki bir günlük
daireyi nereye çizdiğimi de görürüm
size de genel olarak tavsiyem Konfor
alanından çıkmaktan çekinmeyin insanı
büyüten kişisel gelişimine çok katkı
sağlayan bir adım
Öncelikle birinci olarak daha önce
karşılaşmadığımız zorluklarla
karşılaşıyorsunuz ve bunların bir
üstesinden gelme yöntemi buluyorsunuz bu
sizi psikolojik olarak da çok güçlü
yapıyor
kendi sınırlarınızı zorluyorsunuz daha
önce
yapamadığınızı düşündüğünüze
yapamayacağını düşündüğünüz şeyleri
belki yapmaya başlıyorsunuz kendi
sınırlarınızı öğrenmeye başlıyorsunuz
işliyor daha fazla şey hakkında daha
fazla bilgi ediniyorsunuz Yeni bir
ortama giriyorsunuz daha fazla
insanlarla insanlarla iletişime
geçiyorsunuz Yani genel itibariyle bir
insan olarak ufkumuz gittikçe artmaya
başlıyor
Dolayısıyla Sizlerin de tavsiyem Konfor
alan dışı da kesin bir şey yok Bir
belirsizlik var ve ihtimaller var ama o
ihtimalleri gidip keşfetmeye değecek
diye düşünüyorum teşekkürler
[Alkış]